this is Colonel Gaddafi's legacy to his
people at should be Central Hospital
doctors are treating two young boys
brought in after an explosion believing
the war was over twelve-year-old Abdul
and seven-year-old were deer had gone
back to their school only to discover a
cache of unexploded ammunition stashed
away Gaddafi's forces would ears hand
was blown off as they played with a
grenade he suffered eighty percent burns
have lost all the skin on his face and
abdomen nulliparous London alone this
man tried to rescue them other present
of the bar as he explains what happened
on the boys screams can be heard in the
background what are the other plant
growth in a muzzle for heaven side by
side there now fighting for their lives
innocent to the dangers of the weapons
of low too much drama for children
review because the she-demon be the most
I'm the surface of house and this was
the good be there but they don't know
anything about it is over her hitch a
lot of their this woman Abdul is brought
back from the x-ray
the blast blew the flesh of his legs
down to the bone he's likely to submit
but he'll need expert plastic surgery
something Tripoli's burgeoned hospitals
are unable to provide but why dear the
boy without a face is struggling Super
Tuesday why could definitely I can't say
anything this picture look them up me go
this was a war generation that's little
consolation for the grieving family of a
little boy called whad'ya from Tripoli